welcome back comprehensive dental care
the sponsors of this segment are
dedicating to helping people's teeth
look great and stay functional here's
how
it's estimated that over 175 million
americans have at least one missing
tooth so comprehensive dental care is
here to educate that population on their
best options my practice is focused
mainly on dental implants and
single tooth
restorations and full arch
replacement of teeth
i've been doing dental implants for 25
years
i am a
diplomat of the american board of oral
implantology a recognized
dental implant specialist in other words
dr hendrickson knows what he's doing
he's also one of the national full art
restoration trainers for highbridge
dental lab which helps his practice stay
focused on comfort aesthetics and
function if they come in and they're
wearing a denture
like this
we know statistically that they've lost
about 90 percent of their
function they've lost taste because this
covers the roof of their mouth
often times their anatomy
limits the stability of this in their
patient's mouth so they have to perhaps
live with denture adhesive all the time
with the high bridge the full arch
restoration is fixated and screwed into
the patient's mouth it's going to fit
feel and function
the most natural
it's going to give them their ability
back to eat
and enjoy foods another reason why
patients prefer the functional hybrid
system is because it supports optimal
bone health over time
the bone in the jaw melts away
if we take the teeth out we know for a
fact that every year the patient comes
back with the denture in place
they're going to lose gum tissue and
bone the full arch implants stimulate
the bone and restores its health and
functionality making the implant last a
lifetime you know if you come to me and
say greg you know what the teeth are
kind of worn down it's been 10 years
since you put these in i can go ahead
and remove these from the patient's
mouth send them back to the laboratory
and they literally do a retread on these
for less than the cost of a crown you
have a new set of teeth and maintenance
with regular dentures you're looking at
five to seven hundred dollars per reline
now according to dr hendrickson the
process of putting the hybrid in is
relatively pain free patients typically
say the first 18 hours are the worst
with some soreness the next day the
surgery is typically done in the morning
and we bring it back in the next day and
we do a digital scan
and three weeks later we can screw the
your teeth into your mouth and they're
done you know if you look at somebody's
face and eyes
that have dental problems
um
it may sound cliche but sometimes they
kind of come in kind of lifeless because
they
they're not they don't like their smile
they're not happy with it so they're not
smiling
and when we can give them that smile
back their whole face lights up you can
visit comprehensive dental care for a
free consultation with dr hendrickson
himself to discuss your needs and your
new smile
thank you to comprehensive dental care
for sponsoring this segment you can find
them in henderson for more call
or 702-735-3284 nvdentist.com